so defining who do you want to be in
love and how do you embody her how do
you breathe like her how do you walk
through the grocery store like her and
how I do this how I help people become
artists with their body a lot of times
comes down to creativity so I'll give
these spontaneous practices like all
right you're you're being a hum drum
woman I want you to go Sing Down the
grocery aisle or maybe I'll have them do
something like go to a cafe and write a
stranger a poem and then have the
waitress take it to them and then you
just sign it anonymously and all these
little creative things that help them
like break out of the habitual pattern
like break out of the like a like I'm
collapsing in in love and instead begin
to open in Love by choosing to do these
things it's not just about what you want
it's about how you offer how you offer
in love